Good morning, everybody.
I'm Lauren Byers. I'm a thoracic medical oncologist and thoracic
section chief at MD Anderson Cancer Center, and I'm very
pleased to welcome all of you to the Dharma
Master Jian Tie Advances in Lung Cancer
Research Session.
Dharma Master Jian Tie, for whom this session is
named, was a brave, young abbess
who dedicated her life to Dharma teaching.
She was a never smoker who was diagnosed with lung cancer.
Although not available to her at the time, targeted
treatments are now available for the mutation that was
identified in Dharma Master
Jian Tie.
According to her wishes and in memory of Dharma Master
Jian Tie, her family established an endowment to
support the Dharma Master Jian Tie Advances in
Lung Cancer Research Session, the Dharma Master Jian
Tie Symposium and Targeted Therapy, and the Dharma
Master
Jian Tie Symposium in Biomarkers.
The family's goal is to foster cancer research that
leads to new drug therapies
so that patients with cancer will live longer, have better
quality of life, and potentially reach a cure in
select cases.
So I'm very pleased to introduce our first
speaker today for the panel.
Dr. Osar is an associate professor of medicine at Harvard
Medical School and a medical oncologist at Dana-Farber
Cancer Institute in the Lowe Center for Thoracic Oncology.
Dr. Osar completed his undergraduate studies at Oberlin College and
received his MD and PhD from Albert Einstein
College of Medicine. He did his residency at
Brigham and Women's Hospital and fellowship
in medical oncology at Dana-Farber.
He has a very long and distinguished
publication record,
and is currently focusing on
research into CRISPR-Cas9 to understand the mechanisms
that regulate lineage transcription, identity, and novel
targeted therapeutics for small cell lung cancer.
Okay. Well, thank you so much to the organizers and the
invitation to speak, Dr. Byers. So I'm going to talk to you today
about
overall interest in our lab related to regulation and therapeutic
vulnerabilities of small cell lung cancer transcription
factors. Here's my disclosures. So this session's about small cell
lung cancer that accounts for approximately 13% of lung
cancers, and genomically, it's characterized by
near universal loss of function mutations in RB and
P53. And in contrast to non-small cell lung
cancer, small cell lung cancer lacks recurrently mutated
oncogenic drivers.
So over the past several years, through many
groups in the field, it's been appreciated that there are,
although genomically more homogeneous,
epigenetically or transcriptionally, small cell lung cancer is
characterized by these lineage transcription factor subtypes.
So you can think of this broadly as neuroendocrine
subtypes, which make up about 80% of small cell lung cancer, and
non-neuroendocrine subtypes. And within these neuroendocrine subtypes, they're
marked either by ASCL1 dominantly or
neuroD1, and then the non-neuroendocrine subtypes are marked by
Pou2f3 or a triple-negative subtype.
So this has led to a framework to provide personalized
targeted therapeutic strategies, and I think several groups in the field have
identified subtype-specific vulnerabilities.
And so we've been interested really in that these transcription
factors themselves are dependencies in the small cells that
express them. And so we've been doing CRISPR screening to understand
the activity and the regulation of these transcription factors.
I'm not going to go into these projects today, but I'd encourage you to check
out this publication below on Pou2f3.
And so although these transcription factor subtypes are dominantly
expressed and driven by one of the transcription factors, it's been
appreciated that there's intratumoral heterogeneity, and this is
particularly true for ASCL1 and
neuroD1, where about a third of the tumors
express both transcription factors, either in the same cell or in mutually
exclusive cells. And then studies from a couple
different groups, Trudy Oliver's lab, then my lab, found that
genomic alterations in small cell lung cancer can drive
subtype plasticity. So these are just two examples.
This will become important later on.
And so apart from these subtypes
having dependencies in the transcription factors that express them, these
transcription factor programs actually lead to expression of cell
surface antigens. And this has been a really
huge clinical breakthrough of finding
tumor-selective cell surface targeting strategies. And I think Dr.
Byers in the second talk will talk about this broadly.
And three of the targets are DLL3, CES6, and
B7H3, among others. I'm going to specifically talk about
DLL3 in this talk, and a new story that's actually on
bioRxivAnd so DLL3 is most
highly expressed in the ASCL1 subtype of small cell lung cancer.
And that's really because DLL3 is an ASCL1 target gene.
But it's also expressed at very high levels in the neuro D1 subtype, although a
little bit lower levels than ASCL1.
In the PALCH2-F3 subtype, that non-neuroendocrine subtype either
expresses lower or no expression of
DLL3. And so there's several therapeutics in
development targeting DLL3. The most advanced is this
therapeutic tarlatamab, which is a DLL3 bispecific
T-cell engager. So tarlatamab targets
DLL3, CD3 induces T-cell killing of tumor cells
that express DLL3. And this is what I'd argue is probably
one of the biggest clinical breakthroughs of the past several decades.
This is now approved in the second line, for small cell
lung cancer, with a response rate of 35% to
40% and a duration of response of seven to nine months.
But the biomarkers and mechanisms of response and
resistance are not well understood.
And so we really took a two-pronged approach here to
understand determinants and mechanisms of response and
resistance. And this was a wonderful collaboration with
Matt Friedman's lab and Silven Baca's lab at DFCI, and
really beautifully co-led by two fantastic trainees,
Damien Vasseur, postdoc in Matt's lab, and Shin Saito, a postdoc in
my lab. And so what we did really was use
cell-free ChIP-seq from plasma of
patients receiving standard of care tarlatamab prior
to treatment, on treatment, and an acquired resistance,
and in parallel, developed mouse models of
tarlatamab sensitivity and resistance.
And I'll show you how these findings really converged on some
key, I think, fundamental concepts related to this drug.
And so cell-free ChIP-seq, this is an assay from
plasma developed by Silven Baca and Matt Friedman.
And basically, from one ml of plasma can do cell-free
ChIP-seq on histone marks that really correlate with gene
expression. So this is H3K27 acetylation, H3K4
trimethylation, H3K36 trimethylation.
And small cell lung cancer is really an ideal approach for these liquid biopsies
because it has this high cell-free DNA tumor fraction, very
challenging to biopsy, and it's really driven, as I
mentioned, more epigenetically and transcriptionally and not
as much
heterogeneity with the mutations.
So from this cohort that I'm going to talk about, we had 46
patients receiving standard of care tarlatamab, 22 had
clinical benefit, 18 had no clinical benefit.
This is by radiographic response.
So this is in line with response rates seen in larger trials.
And so although these histone marks correlate with gene expression, we
really wanted to be able to more predict gene expression
from plasma. And fortuitously, Goong Galati, who
is a postdoc in Matt Friedman's lab, developed this approach
really by aggregating these histone marks from plasma
and really matching it to the ground truth of RNA-seq
in tumors. And he developed this approach called APEX.
I'm not going to go into detail about it, but you can read about it in this
preprint. In this, he could really correlate single gene
expression at a Spearman correlation of 0.8.
So this is pretty good for inferred RNA-like expression.
And so we applied this to our cohort.
And basically on the right is patients with clinical benefit, on the
left, patients with no clinical benefit.
And just as a sanity check, we are excited to see DLL3.
So this is genome-wide analysis.
But more broadly, what we found is this was the signatures
associated with response were related to many different genes expressed
in the ASCL1 subtype. So this to us suggested that it's actually the
subtype that's correlated with the response, not just DLL3.
So then we did a subtype analysis from the cell-free ChIP-seq
data using APEX, and this is consistent with the APEX results,
sort of at the single gene level. We assigned subtypes,
and the proportions of subtypes are roughly proportional to what we've
seen in patients. And what we found is that really the
ASCL1 subtype highly correlated with the response.
80% of patients with the subtype responded.
None of the PALCH2-F3 patients, although low numbers,
responded, and this was sort of in line with low DLL3.
But I think what was surprising is that neuro D1 subtype,
despite having high levels of DLL3, you can see an example here,
high DLL3 neuro D1 really had very poor
responses, and this will make a little more sense later on.
So now we turn to the mouse, and we
made a syngeneic mouse model to study tarlatamab.
I'm not going to go into a lot of details about the GEM model, but just to say
that from a BLK6 genetically engineered mouse model, we could
isolate tumors and build a syngeneic model that could go back into
BLK6 mice. And what's important to know is that this is an
ASCL1 subtype model. Doesn't express other
transcription factors. And so we could first show that this expresses
DLL3, but importantly, that tarlatamab recognizes
this mouse DLL3, and we could knock out DLL3 and
abrogate the tarlatamab binding.
And we could perform co-culture assays.
Now, this is with human T-cells that basically in the presence of
tarlatamab, you induce a dose-dependent cell killing,
and this was abrogated again by CRISPR inactivation of
DLL3.
But in contrast to
tarlatamab binding mouse DLL3, it does not bind mouse
CD3, and so we had to use a BLK6 transgenic
miceThat where our
company replaced mouse CD3 with human CD3.
So then we ran this through efficacy studies.
And so we basically injected subcutaneous tumors
treated with tarlatamab, and this model has an exquisite response,
really all the mice from the initial cohort had a complete
response, really with three doses out to 160 days.
And this was on target because we saw nothing in black six mice
with mouse CD3, an unrelated bispecific T-cell
engager, BCMA BiTE that
doesn't bind the antigen, but binds human
CD3, did not respond. And remarkably, we could treat
mice really at their endpoint with tarlatamab in tumors that are over
two centimeters and get these complete responses.
And so, thus far, our data suggests in human and
mouse that the ASCL1 subtype is correlated with
response to tarlatamab. So then what happens at acquired resistance?
And so now we turn back to the patients.
And so some of the patients started to develop acquired resistance.
You can see this patient where the tumor fraction increased and
radiographically confirmed a acquired resistance at a little
over 7.5 months. And then we applied APEX really in the
same patient at acquired resistance versus
baseline. And what we saw remarkably was that at
acquired resistance, at baseline, if you compare on the right
side, the genes associated with the ASCL1 subtype went
down, so DLL3 went down. But interestingly, if
you look on the left, so this is what goes up at acquired resistance,
it was many genes associated with the neurod1 subtype.
And so this suggested an ASCL1 to neurod1
subtype selection. You could actually see this at the single gene
locus of neurod1 turning on, DLL3 turning
off and related to subtype signatures.
And so then we had another patient, this is just another vignette, you can read
about other examples in the preprint, that developed an isolated
adrenal
MED that was resected. And really the plasma before it was
resected showed retained DLL3, so high
ASCL1, high DLL3, and that was confirmed by IHC.
But then when we looked at the adrenalectomy, so now this is on tissue, we
were surprised to see that the bulk of cells were T-cells, and
these expressed markers of exhaustion and
markers of regulatory T-cells with FoxP3.
So this was a setting of retained DLL3
suggestive of a defective T-cell response.
So now we'll go back to mouse, and we found some of the same findings.
So we basically treated mice continuously with tarlatamab,
and although they had initial response, occasional mice
would develop acquired resistance.
So from this model, TR2,
we basically made a tumor and a cell line, and this showed
that same pattern where ASCL1's retained, but
neurod1 turns on, DLL3 goes down, and then you
can see this is confirmed by IHC of the tumors on the right.
We could do RNA-seq and ChIP-seq from these cell lines and
tumors and basically show that
neurod1 turns on. So these are different histone marks
correlated with gene expression.
And if we look at signatures, we see really at the acquired
resistance, ASCL1 genes go down
and neurod1 go up. So this is again consistent with a
subtype switch.
So if this is really a cell autonomous mechanism of
resistance, then it should be retained from the cell line and be able to be
transplanted into a mouse. And so we basically did a
competition experiment, where we took the parental sensitive
lines on one flank, the acquired resistant line on the other,
and then we established tumors treated with tarlatamab.
And indeed, the resistance pattern was retained.
So the resistant tumors grew out in the same mouse, the sensitive
tumors responded. And then we basically harvested
tumors at their endpoint doing flow and IHC.
And so consistent with tarlatamab-dependent killing, we see
infiltration of T-cells. And we can do this in larger cohorts as well.
So far I've shown you that neurod1 is at least correlated
with resistance, but we wanted to know is this causative?
And so we took the syngeneic mouse cell line.
We could put in exogenous neurod1, this is with
lentivirus. And then do the same experiment in mice, where we
basically treated these tumors with tarlatamab.
And what we saw in contrast to the parental tumors that all
responded, the ones with neurod1 overexpression, although they
responded initially, we got early resistance.
And so four out of seven tumors developed early resistance.
And we look at the tumors at their endpoint, so this is with some
controls on the left, but these are neurod1 overexpressed tumors
treated with vehicle or tarlatamab.
You see in the presence of tarlatamab, when you have
neurod1, DLL3's lost. So this suggested to
us actually that neurod1's causative and under
selective pressure by tarlatamab, it induces loss of
DLL3. We're still investigating this mechanism.
So then we went back and we said, can we inject many more mice, develop
other models of acquired resistance?
And so we identified five additional models of acquired resistance.
Number two was the reference, the one I've been talking about, but number six looks
a lot like number two with high
neurod1, low DLL3. But interestingly, there are
four tumors in the middle here that developed resistance
that retained DLL3. And interestingly, these actually all turned on
neurod1, which suggests there may be selective pressure to really
turn on neurod1 early on, but this wasn't sufficient for resistance
because DLL3'sIntact, at least tumor cell
autonomous resistance. But then when we looked at these tumors by flow,
we could see, again, T cell phenotypes.
So 40% of the tumor cells, or the T cells
of CD4, were marked by regulatory markers, and the T
cells, CD8 T cells, were exhausted.
And so in summary, these findings really converged
from mouse models and human cell-free plasma.
CHIP-seq really shows that the
ASCL1 subtype with high DLL3
really are the subtype that's most benefiting from tarlatamab.
But once you treat with tarlatamab, you start to develop cell intrinsic
selection pressure on the intrinsic side and the extrinsic
side. And really on the intrinsic side, this induces
neuroD1 that can then promote
DLL3 loss or T cell dysfunction through
regulatory T cells, exhausted T cells.
So I'd like to thank the people that did the work.
Damion Shin, two highly talented post-docs who led
this work, collaboration with Matt Friedman, Silvan Baca's lab.
I'd like to thank our other collaborators, our funding sources, and most
importantly, the patients and families that made this work
possible. So thank you.
I'll take a few questions if there are any.
Hi. Beautiful talk. So maybe I missed it or maybe you are
investigating this, but I didn't get, so when
under pressure of tarlatamab, there is DLL3 loss and
neuroD1 induction. But
is that all, or tarlatamab can just induce
the depletion of the DLL3 expression and then
these results in the resistance?
Yep.
Have you considered that?
Yep. So we do have... Just for sake of time, I did not go over the...
We have one case, so we think it's less frequent where there's isolated DLL3 loss,
but clearly we need larger numbers.
So I think isolated DLL3 loss likely will happen.
That patient did not. There was no mutations in DLL3, but it seems
silencing, and it wasn't associated with neuroD1.
More commonly, we're seeing neuroD1 go up across mouse and human,
and we do think that's causal in that when there's neuroD1, we don't know the
mechanism that it promotes DLL3 loss, but it's
indirect, right? In the cell lines outside of the mouse, it
doesn't down-regulate DLL3, but under the selective
pressure it does. So that mechanism still needs to be worked on.
So there is some sort of signaling through DLL3
that is actually inducing this?
Well, I think it's somehow through neuroD1, but we don't think it's direct.
Actually, we think it's some mechanism that causes loss of
DLL3, and actually we're still investigating that.
We don't even really know at what level that is.
Thank you.
Question?
Yep. I have to lean my head up a little bit.
Matt, awesome talk, awesome work, and probably one of the most important
questions for patients
in small cell, so really impressive.
For the
tumors that switch to neuroD1 and lose DLL3, just trying
to reconcile that with some of the
published or unpublished serial biopsy work.
If you take those tumors off selective pressure of tarlatamab and you just keep
growing them, does DLL3 flicker back on, or is this a
permanent epigenetic or transcriptional switch where DLL3
is off and it stays off?
We don't know in mice, so we've never tried that.
Actually, this model's so sensitive, it's very hard to get acquired
resistance tumors. So that was many, many mice.
But the cell lines where we've taken them out and tried to turn
DLL3 back on has been challenging.
So it doesn't yet. It's retained in the cell lines, and we haven't gotten DLL3 back
on. No mutation, though.
Okay, one more question.
Tamar Ziel, AbbVie.
Can I ask three questions?
Oh, sure. That's fine, yeah. I mean, well, yeah.
Yes. One is related. So when you have the epigenetic switch
and you lose DLL3,
do
you also lose other lineage markers such as SES6, or is SES6
maintained?
Good question. So in the limited models we've seen SES6
retained. Actually, in the mouse model it goes up.
But in the human model, yeah, it's retained.
And B7H3, I'm assuming also is maintained because it's not
related to any linear.
Yeah.
We could look at B7H3. I remember SES6 because it's one of the
outliers, but yeah, it definitely wasn't one of the most down-regulated
genes.
Okay. And my next question is about the T cells portion.
At baseline, do you see any
dysfunction of T cells, if it's exhaustion, senescence, et cetera,
that are associated
with the response or the acquired resistance?
I think it's a good open question. So yeah, we haven't looked at that
extensively sort of in the human tumors.
It's hard because we're trying to think about how we can use plasma to look at T
cells.
Yeah.
It's much easier to look at tumor cells.
We can talk a little more offline. It's complicated.
I do think that may be important, but it's all sort of hypotheses at this point.
Maybe another question, maybe it's an open question.
Do we understand from the initiation of treatment,
how quickly can one lose DLL3 and/or
the T cells become dysfunction?
Is there an issue of timing?
Yeah.
It happens first or is it patient dependent?
Well, I think it's variable from patient to
patient, but the duration of response has been somewhere between seven and 10
months, depending on the trial. So that's sort of...
But it's a wide range.
Thank you. Very elegant work. Thanks.
Thank you.
Great. Well, thank you very much.
Great. Thank you so much, Matt. I think this is a really
incredibly exciting time in small cell lung cancer and other
high-grade neuroendocrine cancers to have not one,
but multiple new therapeutics coming into the space with a
variety of different targets, especially related to
surface targeting approaches, but then also with different mechanisms that can be
used
in new ways that we haven't had before.
So I think this is a really interesting question.
I think one of the things that'll be great to see is, as more patients are
followed with cell-free DNA,
we'll understand better, hopefully, the
resistance and evolution, and also maybe getting to where we can
predict what the resistance may be and
continue to home how we use these different approaches.
These are my disclosures.
So I think you've, again, have already heard a
great
story around
using tarlatamab, trying to understand what's going on in terms of the
setting of resistance and the mechanisms through which that may be
happening, which I think is really important.
I'm going to talk a little bit more about another class of therapeutics that are
now being used in many clinical
trials, several of which have advanced to phase three, which are the
antibody drug conjugates.
As well as there are other surface targeting approaches, such as CAR
Ts, that are also
in current clinical trials. So again, I think it's a new
and abundant
opportunity for thinking about how we can use the surface
targeting approaches to hopefully treat
patients much more effectively, and also thinking about
how we can start
at the beginning of this journey, thinking about how we can personalize treatment
and what biomarkers and tools we'll need to do that.
Just as a snapshot here, when we think
about the antibody drug conjugates,
many of the same targets are being looked at in different
programs. So,
targets such as B7H3, CES6,
Trop-2, and of course, DLL3.
Patients that are going onto these trials are
patients who have received prior treatment, and so the fact that not only
are there encouraging response rates, but they're higher than what we
have seen in the past with other types of therapies that we've
had available in the second-line
treatments
setting for patients.
So one of the clinical trials that I've had the opportunity to be
part of is the CES6 ADC.
This is the ABBV-706
ADC. And I have to say that the first time I saw this data, it
actually gave me goosebumps because we don't normally see waterfall plots that
look like what we see with our colleagues who use EGFR
inhibitors or other types of very highly active
therapeutics.
In addition to the responses that we're seeing in
small cell lung cancer, one of the other things that was really an
incredible opportunity,
and that was the opportunity to include
other high-grade neuroendocrine patients in these
trials. And as you can see on the right side, which are the patients with the
high-grade neuroendocrine cancers, this would include patients, for example,
who had small cell of the bladder or small cell of the
cervix, Merkel cell cancer. Many types of cancers that
often historically have been excluded in clinical
trials with the idea, let's wait and see how it works in small cell and
then go from there. But instead, this was done in
parallel, and I think again, it's very exciting
to have the type of activity that we were seeing
here. The other thing that I wanted to show is
patients were also responding very quickly, and so
they felt a lot better, which was great.
I had patients who came back a week later and
all of a sudden they weren't having pain anymore.
And I have this picture up here. First of all, I have to give full credit that
my daughter caught this fish. This is not my fish.
But I have this picture up here because we ended up having many
of our patients who are on
this and other trials that felt so well with some of these
new therapeutics that they were taking trips to go to
Alaska to go fishing, which I think is a sign that
we're making some progress. In fact, we have a partnership now with a
hospital in
Alaska that can actually make sure that we're getting all the PKs and the blood
draws and everything we have to do so they can stay on
study but also get some fishing in.
As I've been thinking about the different types of therapeutic
opportunities, again, with surface targeting modalities, so
thinking about not just the T cell engagers,
but also the ADCs and radioligands.
We can start to think about things
in terms of could we
move beyond traditional chemotherapy?
Could we replace chemotherapy, for example, with an
antibody drug conjugate?
Will the T cells become either an
addition to or a alternative to
immune checkpoint blockade? And so I think, again, this really opens a lot of
opportunities. And one of the things that I'm very excited about
is that
we now have activated, across several
sites,
theFirst, to my knowledge, clinical
trial that is looking at this question of whether or not we can
potentially replace frontline chemotherapy with
ADC, with the CES6 ADC. So again, I think this is
something that we wouldn't necessarily have expected to be available
and something that would be feasible
maybe even a year or two ago. But I think that
this is, again, a kind of a new
juncture with treating small cell lung cancer.
In thinking about the surface targets, the other thing that we
go back to is thinking about the different molecular subtypes
that are consistently seen
across small cell lung cancer. So we've seen through looking at
some of the big phase three trials like CASPIAN and EMPOWER and
other studies,
that we do see these distinct molecular groups, and they have different features,
including, as you would expect, differences in terms of some of the surface
targets. And so this was a study that Carl Gay and
colleagues
led looking at differences in terms of surface
targets and how they were expressed
depending on different subtypes, so the
ASCL1 neuro D1, PAL2F3 and inflamed.
And so,
for example, V7H3,
it is expressed similarly across the subtypes,
but if we look at DLL3, we know
that
PAL2F3, for example,
predicts a very low expression of DLL3 and
similarly with some of the other neuroendocrine targets, such as CES6, they're
relatively lower in the PAL2F3
compared to the other
subtypes. And so again, I think this gives us a
path to think about how we might personalize some of these
approaches
and thinking about how we might combine them as well, especially if we're
seeing changes where we might need to be targeting two
transcriptional programs.
One of the things I wanted to really highlight here is that, again,
with
our colleagues
at MD Anderson and elsewhere, we are now taking what we're
learning in small cell lung cancer into these other high-grade
neuroendocrine cancers.
One of the things that we found early on after tarlatamab was approved was that
many patients who had high-grade neuroendocrine cancers were having a
difficult time getting access to tarlatamab.
And so
we developed a CLIA IHC in-house. We've now screened more
than
400 patients to look at their DLL3 expression.
And many of our patients with these other neuroendocrine cancers,
including,
for example, Merkel cell carcinoma
and others that I mentioned before,
have been receiving treatment with
tarlatamab and several showing
clinical benefit. And so again, I think it just highlights again that for
many of these targets that we're thinking about in small cell lung cancer, that
there are opportunities elsewhere.
And so, I think this, again, opens doors
for patients that often have not had as many opportunities
for these newer therapeutics.
The other thing is we have a
research platform where we approach all of our patients to see if they would like
to participate so that we can learn as much as we can, as
quickly as we can from each patient.
And as part of that, patients who have a biopsy and are a part of the research
program,
we've been able to make
100 PDX models now representing both small cell
lung cancer, relapsed and treatment naive, as well
as models for the other high-grade neuroendocrine cancer.
And we're really excited about that because I think that will help us to be able to
model and study,
expand our understanding of where these therapeutics can
provide benefit.
And
related to that, I just want to also recognize all of our faculty
who are experts
in neuroendocrine cancers of different areas.
So we have
our prostate, breast,
GU, GYN, et cetera,
and really are an incredible
team of-- We have a working group with people who
bring their expertise to our clinical trials and our
research that we're doing together.
So
just turning to where we need to be going next is, I think
whenever we have therapeutics that are
showing promise and showing activity, we also need to be thinking about how is the
cancer going to become resistant and how are we going to anticipate that?
We know that
many of the ADC programs are using
Top1
payloads, and so we have data that we're showing here at the conference in
some of the poster sessions,
where we have biomarkers, including things like Schleffen 11,
that are demonstrating
that they may be helpful in terms of understanding from
a biomarker perspective who are those patients that are going to get the most
benefit from specific payloads, and also what are the
mechanisms of resistance that may be emerging
over the course of treatment.
So this is just a little...
I can't see the timer from where I am, so just checking to make
sure.So,
anyway, I just wanted to highlight
some data that's from
Dr. Kavya Ramkumar in my group. She actually is
currently
presenting her poster now, but she's been doing a lot of work
looking again at biomarkers for the payloads
for ADCs and
has some nice data supporting the schleffen expression,
which we know also is predictive of chemotherapy
sensitivity that could be a very
potentially useful biomarker for the
ADC payloads as well. And again, the
schleffen 11 has been used in several clinical trials, including some ongoing
trials,
to identify and select patients for certain therapeutics.
And so it's something that could be leveraged
quickly to see if that might be a straightforward IHC, for
example, that might help to see who's most likely to benefit to
specific
therapeutic approaches.
And then
for those cancers that are relatively more resistant, there's
some data presented from
our groups here at the conference also
demonstrating that for those patients that have low schleffen 11 and
therefore less DNA damage in the setting of
these payloads, that there may be an opportunity using ATR
inhibitors to further enhance response to treatment.
So again, I think as
we've all been taught as oncologists, we need to think not just
about how many patients are responding, but
also can we anticipate what the mechanisms of resistance
may be or combinations that would help to further
enhance the activity and the benefit.
So
just again, from a high level, I think this is an
incredibly exciting time. There's going to be a lot of work to do,
but actually having choices to offer patients in the
clinic
is really a nice place to be, and I think we'll have that more and
more. I think there's a growing
number of groups that are really doing great work in terms of biomarkers and
understanding what are the different
therapeutic
opportunities and are there biomarkers that we can develop so that we
can become more and more
precise in terms of how we're using these and how do we select the patients that
are likely to get the most benefit.
And then, of course, the
cancer will continue to change, and so tracking the resistance and
understanding those mechanisms, I think, is one of the next
steps that will be really important.
And
we'll have more to come over the next year, I'm sure, from
people who are working on that. So with that, I just
want to thank all of you for being here and also to
recognize our research team. We have an incredible group of
scientists in the lab, as well as our computational
colleagues and faculty colleagues, including Carl Gay,
John Haymak,
Bingnan Zhang,
and many others. And so thank you for being here today.
Are there questions for Dr. Byers?
Maybe I have one question. I don't know whether you have actually had the chance
to check this, but for the Z6, similar to the
DLL3, is it known whether loss of the antigen is a
potential issue for resistance?
Loss of Z6 expression.
Oh.
Yeah, so
we don't have any data so far on that, but I think it's a good question.
And I think that
with the longitudinal samples, especially from the blood, and being able
to use that as a surrogate to look at some of those questions, I think we'll
be seeing more
hopefully in the next year or so as we have more data on
that.
I was asking this also because different, I think, from the other
three, Z6 is actually reported
that is actually cleaved by an enzyme.
So I was actually wondering whether this is also something that
you're looking at.
Cleavage of the soluble Z6.
Yeah. We have not been specifically looking at that so far, but I think that's
an interesting question.
That was great, Lauren. And the CES six ADC clinical
responses were really amazing.
And so thinking about the previous talk, we might anticipate
more neuro D1 positive patients
progressing on Tarla and now looking for an opportunity.
So I'm curious, I know you showed expression of CES six in the neuro
D1 group, but I'm curious, are you able to link responses in the
trial to neuro D1 versus ASCL1
status and does it look like there's effectiveness in the neuro D1 group?
In terms of the patients from the trials?
Yeah. Right.
I think we have more data from the
ASCL1 subtypes because we've been looking actively at
DLL3, so we know which patients
have a dominant ASCL1
profile. But in terms of the
neuro D1, I don't think we have as much information so far on that, but I think
it's-
And if we assume that you do see nice responses in the neuro D1 group,
would it be worth considering combining a CES six ADC
with tarlatamab to avoid the
resistance arising if it-
Yeah.
So I think that is a really interesting question.
I think that's something-- AndAnd there are trials going on trying to look
at that. And so I think that similar to
traditional approaches of chemotherapy and immunotherapy, then
maybe a T-cell engager and something else that's inducing DNA
damage may be important.
We also don't know to what extent there may be bystander effects as well.
So maybe even if there's a mix of
CES6 high, but other more
neuroendocrine or other
cells that have less expression, they may get
some effective therapeutic
killing as well, just depending
within that area.
Great. Thank you.
That's a great talk, Lauren.
And this is sort of a crystal ball question that's kind of following along from
David's question. Given how urgent it is to start
patients on therapy first line,
and some of what Matt was showing and what you were showing, that
not all small cell has all of these targets expressed,
do you think in four or five years we're going to have
very rapid first-line biomarker-directed therapy?
Or do you think it's going to be we're going to
give a combination that hits all of these targets at once, like
David was saying?
What do you think it will look like in a couple of years?
Yeah. So I think one thing that we're very
proud of, and many
oncologists from multiple institutions have been working on
getting the SWOG PRISM trial up and going, where patients are
getting profiled to see what their molecular subtype is and their
SLUFN11 status. This is a
trial that is
designed to enroll and screen 900 patients.
The turnaround time is one week or less, and so that
was really important because it wasn't going to be feasible to tell people to "Hang
on and we'll let you know" . So I think that was something that's really
important, and it's a CLIA approach where
people can order that if they want that information, then they get
also the mRNA data. So if there are future new targets we're not
even thinking about today, they could go back to that report and that
profiling, and it may be helpful down the road as well.
But I completely agree that for any frontline
trials, we've got to be able to move quickly.
Well, thank you, Dr. Byers, for a great talk.
Great. So I would like to introduce Dr.
Hamsa Venkatesh.
She did her undergraduate degree in chemical biology from the University of
California, Berkeley, and her PhD in cancer
biology from Stanford University.
After completing her post-doctoral work, she joined the Stanford faculty in
2019 and started her cancer neuroscience
program.
She's an assistant professor now at the Brigham and Women's Hospital and
Harvard Medical School.
She's had many recognitions for her
very innovative
research, including the MIT Technology Review
Pioneer under 35, Top 10 Innovator to Watch
under 40,
and she received the Science and SciLife Prize for Young
Scientists.
So Dr. Venkatesh, very pleased to have you today.
All right. Thank you all for being here and
Lauren for the invitation. We've heard some beautiful talks today
about small cell lung cancer and the clinical work and a lot of the cell intrinsic
mechanisms that may contribute to disease
progression. But today, I'll be talking more about the microenvironmental
determinants of small cell lung cancer, particularly in the context of the nervous
system. So my initial work really studied the role of
neural activity and neurons in the context of primary brain
cancers. And to make a long story short, what we discovered and what you can see
here in this video is that these tumors are indeed electrically active.
And so really appreciating the electrical component of their pathophysiology has
given us a new handle on how to think about and attack
these diseases. And so in thinking about other cancers that may benefit
from this neuronal input, our lab became particularly
interested in brain metastases, and in particular, small cell lung
cancer brain metastases.
Now, of course, I'm sure this crowd knows brain metastases as a whole
outnumber all primary brain cancers combined by about tenfold.
And so clinically, that's an extremely important issue.
And small cell lung cancer has an extremely high propensity specifically to
metastasize to the brain, but also presents a really interesting case
study because they are derived from these pulmonary neuroendocrine cells.
And so at baseline, we have this extremely neural
phenotype. And so we started by just looking at these
patient samples. And as you can see here, as opposed to these primary
nodular tumors that we think about when we think about
brain metastases, we actually see a lot of evidence of this axonal
infiltration, as you can see here labeled in brown.
And in the areas of the tumors that are actually infiltrated by these axons,
we actually see a higher rate of proliferation or higher growth of these tumors,
really suggesting that perhaps in addition to this anatomical
relationship, there may be a functional relationship here as
wellSo we then turned to our Murine models and
used optogenetic technology. And now optogenetics is a really
exciting tool that actually allows us to manipulate the activity of
very specific cortical circuits or any circuit of choice.
In this case, we were manipulating the premotor circuit.
As you can see here, when the light is on, we get this very clear ambulation in
the mouse, telling us that we are indeed activating
that region of interest. And we graft our cells into that region of interest and
can then read out exactly what the cells are doing.
What we find is that just after a single stimulation, we
very clearly see a very clear increase in the proliferation of these
tumors.
We also see a dramatic effect in the invasion capacity of these
cells, really suggesting that there is a true functional effect of these
active neurons on the growth of these tumors within the brain.
So we also wanted to understand a little bit more about the interactions of
these tumor cells and these neurons.
And so we performed ultra structural analyses here using immunoelectron
microscopy, where we can label the tumor cells here with these immunogold
particles, and then look to see how they're interacting with their neighboring
cells. What we found was actually two distinct kind of
characteristics of these cells. In one situation,
we saw these very clear synaptic phenotype, like we saw in our primary brain
tumors as well, where the tumor cells sit postsynaptically, really suggesting they
may be
forming these bona fide synaptic structures with these
presynaptic neurons. We also saw this perisynaptic phenotype that I'll get to
a little bit later in the talk, which are very reminiscent of astrocytes, where
these tumor cells actually sit next to normal neuron to
neuron synapses
in a different capacity.
But focusing first on these synaptic interactions, to kind of probe that a
little bit more, we performed single cell sequencing of these tumor cells
that were either cultured together with neurons in vitro or cultured
alone. And what we found primarily is that the cells that were
cultured together with the neurons had an extremely distinct phenotype.
They look completely different from the cells that were in monoculture.
And that one particular cluster within this kind of co-cultured
group was particularly enriched for a synaptic phenotype for these
neural gene expression programs.
Now moving back to the patient setting, we collaborated with Benjamin Izar at
Columbia University to get our hands on patient small cell
lung cancer brain metastatic tissue, which is actually quite difficult to come by.
And again, what we find is that compared to these extracranial disease sites,
the cells that were isolated from small cell lung cancer brain metastatic
tissue were also enriched for these same synaptic genes and these
same synaptic
neural gene expression programs.
And so we wanted to understand whether or not there was actually a functional role
for these synaptic gene expression programs.
And so we turned to electrophysiology, where we graft these cells back
into the brain, and we use whole cell patch clamp technology to
understand what was happening to these cells in response to neuronal activity.
And indeed, just as we saw in our primary brain cancers, we did see
both spontaneous as well as these evoked
glutamatergic currents that were blocked with MBQS, which is a glutamatergic
receptor inhibitor, really suggesting that they were receiving these depolarizing
currents from glutamatergic neurons.
However, unlike our brain cancers, we actually only saw this in about 5% to
10% of our cells. What we did see in about 50% of our
cells were these GABAergic responses in response to these
GABAergic interneuron
synaptic neurotransmission. Now, that was actually quite striking because we
typically think about glutamate as being an excitatory depolarizing
neurotransmitter in the brain, whereas we think about GABA as being a
hyperpolarizing inhibitory neurotransmitter in the brain.
But in this context, what we actually found was that the small cell lung cancer
cells only in these malignant tumor cells because of their very high
intracellular chloride concentration levels, the GABA in this context was
actually depolarizing as well. And so we now had two different
mechanisms of depolarization, both the glutamate and the GABAergic
neurotransmission, though we found the GABAergic neurotransmission to be
particularly important in this context.
So we then use iPSC-derived neuronal cultures to isolate these
GABAergic interneurons, culture them together with a broad panel of small
cell lung cancer cells. And what you can see here is that in every scenario, in the
presence of these neurons, we see this very dramatic increase in the proliferation
of these cells that was blocked by the addition of either the GABA receptor
blocker Gabazine or tetrodotoxin, which silences
all neuronal activity.
We can come back to our mouse models again using this optogenetic technology.
But here, as opposed to elevating the activity of the entirety of that cortical
circuit, we only specifically express those opsins in those
local interneurons. And in response to that interneuron
activation, we again can recapitulate those effects in different panels
of small cell lung cancer cells, where we again see this very clear
increase in the growth of these tumor cells.
Now knowing that we can depolarize these cells using either
glutamatergic or GABAergic neurotransmission, we again use calcium
imaging, like the videos that I showed you at the beginning.
And similar to the electrophysiological responses, we found both evoked and
spontaneous currents that were blocked in the presence of tetrodotoxin.
So we then just wanted to know, is it the depolarization itself that's inducing
this growth-promoting effect? So we bypassed the neurons
themselves and then expressed the opsins only in the tumor cells
themselves and used the blue light to directly depolarize the
membranes of these cells after having been grafted into the mouse brain.
And indeed, you can see that after three depolarization sessions, we
see this dramatic increase in the overall tumor burden of these small cell lung
cancer cells, really suggesting that it's something about this depolarization
that's driving this growth. So we're still really trying to
understand mechanistically what's going on in the context of this depolarization
and what's driving that growth. But I also just wanted to come back to that
other phenotypeThat I mentioned to you earlier.
In our small cell lung cancer
single-cell
dataset that I told you about, we did see synaptic gene expression in a
particular cluster. However, what we did see additionally was a
separate cluster of cells that was dramatically increased in this more astrocytic
phenotype of the brain. And that really reminded of these
peri-synaptic interactions that I mentioned that we were also found ultra
structurally. And so knowing that astrocytes are really important for
shaping the form and function of these neural circuits, we asked whether or not
there was a reciprocal remodeling of these neural circuits, where a population of
more neuronal-like small cell lung cancer cells could receive the input from the
neurons, but perhaps a differentiation of these cells into a more
astrocytic phenotype was actually working to remodel these neuronal
circuits. Indeed, we do see a morphological change of
a population of these cells, again, in line with this astrocytic phenotype.
And so then using these multi-electrode array recordings, we asked whether or not
the properties of the neurons in culture with these small cell lung cancer cells
were changed. And indeed,
as measured by both spike amplitude as well as by both spike
frequency, we do see that there is evidence of hyperexcitability of
these neurons when cultured together with these small cell lung cancer cells,
really suggesting that there is this feedback mechanism
of these small cell lung cancer cells.
We can, again, move back that into the in vivo context, and using
field potential recordings of our
contralateral non-tumor-bearing side versus our tumor-bearing side, we see
evidence of this increased hyperexcitability neighboring the
tumor, again, suggesting that there is this remodeling effect towards
hyperexcitability that then drives these tumors
to proliferate in response to the activity itself.
So knowing that this synaptic neurotransmission and depolarization is
so important for this growth, we wanted to understand whether or
not blocking synaptic neurotransmission might be therapeutically beneficial
to these small cell lung cancer brain metastases.
And so we used a commonly used anti-epileptic drug called
levetiracetam or Keppra, more commonly known as in the clinic,
that are oftentimes given to patients who present with seizures.
And what we can see is that treatment with levetiracetam actually does dramatically
reduce both tumor burden as well as the cell proliferation of these tumor
cells
in, again, multiple distinct types of small cell lung cancer, really suggesting
that perhaps this novel angle of neurotransmission
and these neural tumor interactions is actually an
axis that may be clinically targetable moving forward.
And so in the context of the brain, we now know that there are multiple
different avenues that we might be able to attack, and we are indeed thinking about
these both direct neuron to tumor mechanisms as well as these
indirect reciprocal remodeling of the tumor microenvironment.
But we also wanted to ask: What then is happening in the context of the primary
lung? If we know that innervation is so important in the brain, which may make
sense, what's going on in the context of the lung?
We know that innervation is particularly important for homeostasis
and regeneration in multiple different organs within the body.
And using our genetic models then, we asked, how does innervation
look in these small cell lung cancers?
So this is a whole cleared lung of a genetic model of small cell lung
cancer, where the tumors are labeled in green and the neuronal fibers are labeled
in red. And what you can immediately appreciate is that the tumors are growing
almost exclusively on top of these fibers and that the tumor cells
themselves are actually quite innervated.
We can actually quantify this innervation, and indeed, we see by
branching the number of nerve terminals and as well as
neurite count, there is a remodeling, even in the lung of these
nerve fibers, really suggesting that there is neuronal recruitment into
these nerve fibers. And so we just asked the question, what happens in the lack of
this nerve fibers? And to ask that question, we performed a
vagotomy on these mice prior to tumor initiation.
And to make a long story short, what we found is that in response to this
denervation, we can dramatically diminish the initiation and growth of
these tumors. And at the six-month time point, you can see that in the
sham-manipulated animals, there are huge tumors in
the entirety of the lung, whereas in the
denervated mice, we barely see any tumors at all.
And that certainly translates to a
massive benefit to survival.
And so just in my last couple of minutes, I just wanted to tell you about another
burgeoning story in the lab, really thinking about the brain-body axis of
these nerve fibers. So if these nerves are being remodeled within
the lung, and we know that these peripheral nerve circuits are indeed
communicating with the brain, we wanted to ask the
question of whether or not there was a broader interaction between the nervous
system and small cell lung cancer progression.
So the first thing we did was actually map the innervation from the lung to the
brain to really understand which of these nerve fibers in the
lung were actually communicating with the brain.
The first-order connection actually happens within that nodose ganglia.
And you can see here that we get a lot of labeling in these tumor-burdened mice in
those nodose ganglia that then translate into higher order brain
regions. The first stop is the brain stem, and then we can see multiple different
regions throughout higher order connections in the brain as well.
So we wanted to understand whether tumor progression within the lung can actually
change the activity of any of these actual circuits within the brain.
So to do that, we did whole-brain clearing and c-Fos labeling to
mark the activity of these neuronal circuits within the brain.
And we found that indeed, we see global dysregulation of brain.
But just to give you a small vignette, one area of particular increase of
activity was actually the VTA, which is a second order or
a much higher order connection. It's not a direct synapse from the lung to the
brain. So it was really particular that we saw a very clear increase in this
particular region itself.So we use calcium
imaging to understand what the responses in the VTA were in response to
AMPA-dependent signaling. And I know I'm a little bit short on time here, so I'll
kind of go through this a little quickly.
But what we find is that in response to this AMPA
stimulus in the tumor-bearing mice, we actually see this very clear
increase in response in the lung tumor-bearing mice, even though we
actually see no disease burden in the brain itself, which really
suggests that there's an actual remodeling of these brain circuits
in response to a
tumor within the lung. So to understand whether or not these were
signals that were communicating via the vagus, we again performed this vagotomy
of these tumor-bearing mice, and again, we're able to see that we can actually
block that response and that this increase in response
then dampens with the vagotomy, really
suggesting that these are signals that are functioning through the
vagus.
Importantly, we wanted to understand whether that
translates to any functional deficits in these mice that have this
altered circuitry within the brain.
And indeed, as the VTA is known for a lot of
motivation and discrimination, we performed a battery of
tests. I'm just showing you an example here, where we actually do see a
change in the phenotype of these animals in terms of how they behave
in the context of motivation.
And so I think it's a really exciting time to, again, just start thinking about how
we reframe our understanding of not only tumor physiology,
but also cancer neuroscience as a whole.
We are thinking a lot about these very local interactions of how
innervation is playing an important role in the context of the local tumor
microenvironment within the brain, within the lung, and we have a lot of ongoing
studies there. But I think there's actually a broader view of thinking about this
as a much more systemic kind of brain-body
interaction and brain-body disease as a whole that I think is going to have really
important
consequences for patients moving forward in terms of their
overall cognition, their quality of life, their response to therapies,
et cetera. So, our lab is really focused, again, on understanding the mechanisms
that
both drive activity-mediated metastases, but also the role of innervation at
the primary site, as well as these more systemic interactions at the
brain-body axes. So, I'm happy to answer questions about any of the
above. I know we've kind of gone through a broad array of different aspects of
cancer neuroscience, but I think particularly, especially in the context of small
cell lung cancer, I think there's
a lot of work that we can do to move this into the clinic that might be hugely
beneficial for the patient. So with that, I'll end.
I'm sorry if I went a little bit over.
Thank all of my funding sources, collaborators, as well as, of course, the
patients and families whose donations without which we couldn't have done this.
So thank you.
Thank you for a fascinating talk. Ita Offringa, USC.
Have you looked at whether the signatures
influence the types of tumors that go to the brain
metastatically? Or you've only been studying them locally?
Because, I mean, does it happen before they go to the brain or-
Yeah, that's a great question. We're actually now trying to do some more lineage
tracing to understand that exact question.
It's very hard to know because we know that in the presence of the brain and the
presence of the neurons, there certainly is some activity-mediated phenotypic
plasticity that occurs within the cells, whether or not there is a
subpopulation of cells at the primary lung site that are particularly
primed to then reach and survive and thrive.
I would have to hypothesize yes, and there's probably a reason why there are
particular types of tumors that have a stronger propensity to
end up at various different sites within the body.
But we're actively working to try to address that question.
And then also a question, so what other phenotypes do the mice have
when you cut the vagus nerve?
That's a great question. Actually, they're totally fine.
We've looked at, of course, their heart rate, their breathing, their other
respiratory... I should mention that this is a unilateral, kind of only
on the right branch of the vagus.
But they're completely fine, actually.
They're able to function with just one side.
Yep.
Hello. This is Hugo from Oncology Bioinformatics team at AbbVie.
Impressive talk. I have a naive question on the
neural features of the small cell.
Sure.
Can you comment on what are those neural features
related to the neuroendocrine? Because-
Mm-hmm
... I have a poster on small cell at the same time.
Yeah.
And I do notice there's a subtype that shows like-
Yeah
... increase on non-neuroendocrine, but neural activities which I have
hard time to explain.
Yeah.
So I want to hear any thoughts you-
That's a great question. So you mean within the subtypes of small cell lung
cancer?
Yeah, or kind of general, like to the neuroendocrine cancer.
Yeah. So, I will say we've only really focused on small cells
so far. It definitely appears that all the subtypes
that we have so far tested, which is only SCLC A,
SCLC N, and SCLC P, do respond at least
proliferatively to neurons. And so that seems to be subtype
agnostic. We
believe that it's more so the SCLC A subtype that seems to be
more prone towards actually receiving that synaptic input.
But I think, again, because there is so much plasticity that occurs, it's really
hard to understand whether or not they're kind of shifting towards one
or the other. So, I don't yet have a great
answer to that question. I don't know if maybe Lauren or Matt have a better answer
to kind of those neural features within the neuroendocrine
tumors themselves.
I definitely don't have a better answer, but I was going to ask you.
It's interesting,
some genomic studies with brain MET show enrichment of PTEN
mutations, although very small numbers.
Sure.
And those tend to be associated with POW2F3. I don't know.
I just wonder
if you could speculate on how maybe a non-neuroendocrine
subtype-
Yeah
... might be able to co-opt the neural interactions.
Yeah. It's a great question. My guess is really, it's
more about plasticity is my thinking.
We actually find that despite the fact that
the SELCA cells seem to take better in the brain, over time
it does seem like they down-regulate ASCL1 and up-regulate neuroD1.
So there's an obvious kind of plasticity that's occurring
there. The
POW2F3, we didn't really see any particular changes then, but I
really don't think we had a high enough N.
So I think it's a really fascinating question and certainly something that is
transcriptionally characteristic of these cells that make them
amenable to thriving in these
spots. And Lauren and I were talking about this earlier.
I think that they must have some cell-specific phenotype
that makes them prone to different organ sites even, and allow
them to thrive. I don't have all those answers.
Great.
Thank you.
Great talk. My question is, does this neuronal interaction
affect the intravasation or extravasation of these
tumor cells? And does that make difference for different
metastatic site, like a bone? Does that share the same
mechanisms?
Yeah, it's a great question. I'm not sure.
We do see that the vessels do seem to kind of get
recruited alongside the nerves when we see this kind of nerve fiber
recruitment. They certainly do go hand in hand, and we know neural activity as a
whole has the ability to open blood
vessels and attract blood vessels and things like that.
So there certainly is some synergy there.
But we haven't really looked particularly at CTCs or extravasation or
things like that in response to activity.
I think that would be a great question to think about moving forward, though.
Great. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you. This is so interesting.
I think it'd be exciting to see as you
continue your work, to see if some of the
medications that are used in neurology that might have some sort of
benefit in terms of disrupting some of those connections.
So anyway, very exciting work. Thank you.
So I'm very pleased to introduce Anne Fish
Stagl, who is our advocate on the panel,
and
we're very pleased to have her here.
So Anne is an oncology nurse and has been associated with lung
cancer for more than 20 years, and in oncology for 40
years.
She was a research nurse at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill,
and she really identified that there was an unmet need
where patients could be seen and followed up by their medical
teams all
at the same time. So I think this really was a step in the
very forward-looking in terms of multidisciplinary
care,
and how she really
built that at UNC.
In 1995, she became the thoracic oncology
research nurse and overall nurse coordinator for thoracic malignancies,
and started the UNC MTOP program that was considered one of
the top thoracic programs in the country.
She's published numerous articles and book chapters
on multidisciplinary care and the
really crucial role for nurse navigators.
After that,
Anne left UNC to start an oncology nurse navigator program
for payers, and she spent the next 11 years at
Biologics building programs and care plans to ensure
compliance and safety for patients receiving drugs from
Biologics.
She has also led, on the clinical side, business development and worked
closely with the pharmaceutical industries to ensure safe
launches for new oncology products,
and has worked closely with payers to educate them on the
need to reimburse for many off-label usages
of oncology therapeutics.
Anne did a short stint in commercial drug launch
consulting before joining LUNGevity
in 2023. She's the
SVP of the patient services and health delivery.
And in her role at LUNGevity, she focuses on awareness,
education, implementation, and initiatives that will
enhance the lives of those touched by lung cancer.
Her team develops and delivers direct patient programming as
well as working on
broader lung cancer initiatives.
And I can say that
the work that they're doing is directly
impacting our scope and ability to do
research in the field. So we're really
excited to have her here and to hear more about your work with LUNGevity.
Thank you, Dr. Byers and the AACR for including
advocacy in this important research
session. I appreciate those of you who have stayed to hear
about advocacy, because I feel like in most places,
people think that advocacy is about events that just
raise money. And so where
do those funds go? So LUNGevity is actually a global
lung cancer advocacy foundation.
And our mantra, if you will, is that we are
transforming lung cancer.
And how do we do that? We stand on certain pillars, and our
pillars are really around research, education,
support, and equity of access for care for
all lung cancer patients and their families.
We have a very active policy team that works on Capitol Hill to
ensure government policies provide more
access to care through our policies, funding for
research, which as you all know, has been a daunting task over these last
couple of years. And I really give a shout-out to my
policy team at LUNGevity, who have faced a lot of
adversity in this area, but nevertheless, never give up.
We work collaboratively with other agencies to ensure
that these goals are met. And I would just point out that in this
picture is our founder and CEO, who
is Andrea Ferris, and she is standing on the lawn in front of the
Capitol, where LUNGevity partnered with much of the lung
cancer community to put flags out during our Lung
Cancer Awareness Month last November.
The white flags that you see in the background simply remind us
of all the lives lost to lung cancer, and that it's still the number
one cancer killer in adults.
The US flags in front represent all of the veterans
who did not lose their life in service, but lost their
lives to lung cancer as well.
So how does advocacy play a role in research?
Here you see our scientific advisory board at LUNGevity,
and some of these faces you will certainly recognize, including Dr. Byers.
This is a unique group of science
physicians that come together and work with us
very collaboratively throughout the year.
But once a year, they get together and award young
investigator awards to promising new scientists so that
they can further their work and ideas.
We also work in clinical trial development.
So again,
we want to ensure that all patient voices have been
included in any trial development.
We have worked tirelessly with many other
advocacy foundations from all disease states,
really, to work with industry
and the NIH to influence the fact that
many patients do not have access to clinical research
simply by means of finances. So supporting
travel, lodging, meals, gas, and even at
many institutions, believe it or not, one of the biggest
deterrents for patients to enter clinical trials is something as
simple as parking. So when we have been able to
influence industry and sponsors to include those
benefits for patients, we've also increased access to clinical
trials.
Through our support systems and through our online social
media campaigns, as well as through our online support groups that we
call virtual meetups, we advertise or
publicize any
access to trials that would benefit our community.
We have a one-on-one navigator that works with
patients
to find clinical trials, to match them with an institution, to get them a
second opinion, and get them into those clinical trials.
And we also have a peer-to-peer group for
patients who are considering clinical trials or don't really understand the
process and want to talk to someone who has gone through that
experience, then we can match them with
those patients who have already entered into clinical trials.
We also have our Patient-Focused Research Center, and many of
you will know Dr. Upal Basu Roy,
who runs our Patient-Focused Research Center, along with
his colleague, Dr. Belinda Keane Kalamanas.
And Patient-Focused really does work to do all of
these things, to create, to support, to cultivate,
and to advance
clinical research within our community.
Some of the questions that Patient-Focused really centers
on are: What kind of barriers do people face when they
try to access screening or early detection?
What kind of barriers do these patients
have to face in terms of earlier diagnosis?
One of the things that we're working on at LUNGevity right now in our
precision medicine group is trying to get more
patients tested for biomarkers in non-small
cell earlier in their diagnosis, and to believe
that a diagnosis is really not a full diagnosis in
non-small cell unless you have that biomarker
information before you make a treatment
decision.How long does it take for patients to
get diagnosed? I think that that's one of the things, and Dr.
Byers was
so generous in her introduction of me, that really
came to mind as one of the reasons that I wanted to implement
multidisciplinary care. As a research nurse in a
rural state-owned hospital, many of my patients were not
even able to come for treatment because they simply didn't have gas
money. So when I went back and looked at the way that we
were having these patients come multiple
times for multiple scans, and at one point, at
UNC in Chapel Hill, our patients were traveling
a minimum of 90 minutes one way.
So why are we having these patients come for multiple
scans over multiple weeks, taking forever to get to
a diagnosis? And then when we got to follow-up, what was happening with these
patients? Who is paying for
scans three months in a row? Who's paying for
lab work three months in a row? So our idea of
multidisciplinary care came into play so that patients could
actually come for one day. I worked
beforehand, hence my being the original
nurse navigator. For these patients who had to travel, I wanted to
make sure that they got as many tests done while they were there as
they possibly could and did not have to make multiple trips.
And the same with follow-up, so that patients came and saw everyone that they
needed to see. So those are the kind of barriers that, as an advocacy
group, we truly address on a daily basis.
Another issue that comes up and has been part of my career
forever is that there is
disparity in care.
And this is from community or rural
practices. Dr. Byers spoke even about the
fact that patients were having problems getting access to
tarlatamab. A lot of times in the community, when this drug was first
introduced, the fact that patients had to be hospitalized for their first
two doses of therapy
was a deterrent to community practices wanting to use the
drug. So another area in which we work very hard
is to make sure that patients get access to
concordant guideline care wherever they are in a system.
We're also looking at young people.
What's happening? We've all heard so much about younger
patients and colorectal carcinoma.
Well, now we're seeing the same thing in lung cancer.
So many younger patients.
We try so hard to stay away from stigma and not
label patients as smokers or non-smokers or light smokers, because it
doesn't really matter. If you have lungs, you can get lung cancer, and we're seeing
that so much more in our younger population.
So what's happening there? How can we support research that looks at
why are so many young patients getting lung cancer?
We also really focus a lot on quality of life.
So how are these patients living with this disease?
And that's where our other
aspects of advocacy come into play, really, and
that's how do we connect our patients with this
science that's so rapidly evolving.
We have lots of events. We have, and I
put here on this slide really to emphasize that
because we have made such great strides in the small
cell community, that we have really picked up our game or tried to
pick up our game in small cell education and what we're doing for the small cell
community. So we've partnered with Dr.
Misty Shiels at Indiana University, who truly
small cell lung cancer is her deep and abiding passion.
She is hosting a Smashers Live Day in Dallas in just a couple of
weeks. We'll be there May 1st through the 3rd.
We have a very separate small cell
Facebook community that's incredibly active.
It's grown from just a few members to over
2,000 members in the last six months.
We have a small cell virtual meetup session.
We also have our lifeline, which is what I was describing.
That's our peer-to-peer, so that patients can actually meet with somebody who
has gone through these treatments before them or considering a clinical trial.
We
do a lot of educational webinars, and we
even have some things on our website, such as our bite
video, for instance. We developed a bite video for
patients that really does describe in a very animated
way and easy for patients to understand what
happens when they get tarlatamab, for example.
We also do programs helping to address all
of the side effects that come with these
therapies. So I could go on and on. I
literally could talk for hours about what we do at LUNGevity,
but I would love for you to check out our website at
LUNGevity.org.
You can do that by just scanning the QR code.
To remember, and please pass on to your patients, for those of you
who actually see patients every day,
make sure that patients are aware that advocacy
really is connecting them as a community, that they are
not alone in their struggle with lung cancer, and that
advocacy is a lot more than just a run or a walk that
raises money. We spend every day trying to make the
lives of our patients better. We have our Hope
Summit that's coming up, which even though it's only in a couple of weeks,
most of those sessions are virtual, so patients can join those
virtually. And later this week, Dr.
Shiels and I will be actually launching our
podcast called "Lung Cancer: Voices of Hope," which will
partner a survivor with an expert to talk
about everyday problems and issues that are happening in the lung
cancer community. A patient gets to talk about their perspective
and what they have gone through and then have questions answered by an
expert. So thank you again to AACR, to Dr.
Byers, for inviting me to do this and to actually share
my passion with you. Thank you.
Thank you so much, Anne.
We're happy to take some questions.
I think maybe I'll start with
something we were talking about earlier, before this session,
about how with tarlatamab, many patients
get very significant changes in terms of
taste, and it can become a huge issue
to patients and also to their loved ones who are trying to feed them whatever
they can and whatever they'd be willing to eat.
And I think one of the things, as we were talking, Anne was
talking about how
some of the patients and families had identified some things that seemed to improve
some of those
taste symptoms. And it reminded me of
with some of our early
targeted therapeutics, where there were a lot of very specific rashes
and other side effects that patients were sort of trying to figure out how to
navigate. And as these communities came together, where you had
patients with EGFR lung
cancers or ALK, that we were learning so much
from our patients, and they were connecting and having Facebook
groups. And I think the same thing with, from what I'm hearing
in terms of what you were talking about today with the tarlatamab, and so, learning
from our patients as well as
not just through clinical trials, but their experience and how we
can help other
patients is really
important.
Absolutely. And I will say this,
that I can't say enough about Dr.
Misty Shields, because she actually moderates the
SMASHers Facebook page every day herself and
answers questions directly on that
Facebook community. So it's absolutely true. In fact, what Dr.
Byers was alluding to is that we have had a
patient who's been through about 15 or 16
cycles of tarlatamab now, and she has just
done her own research and has posted for those patients
a list of foods that taste good and those foods
that taste bad. And she has come up with
some-- I guess on Amazon, there are these
little almost like mints or
lozenges that were intended to help patients who had
intense sour taste to any food,
that it makes that food sweeter. And what she
has discovered is that if patients will suck on one of these
little Magic Berry, they're called, lozenges for
just a few minutes before their meal, they're actually getting through
their meal
with things tasting pretty normal. So you're absolutely correct, Dr.
Byers. We learn so much from our own community, and
they share so much with each other.
And then we, as an advocacy group, we try to sort of harness
that. What is going on in the community? What are we hearing?
What are the questions we're hearing? What are the problems that people are having?
That's where we really learn so much.
And then through these other events, like our podcasts, our
SMASHers Fireside Chats, our Hope Summit, our SMASHers
Live, through all of those, we really try to harness that and
then give that back to the community in a way that they can learn.
Well, thank you so much for being here.
One of the biggest changes that I've probably seen on the advocacy
side is now many, many clinical
trials have reimbursement for travel.
So patients that are having to get on an airplane every three weeks to come for
their appointments,
or travel multiple hours. Now, in retrospect, it seems kind
of crazy that patients were having to
take on all of those additional expenses
to participate. But I think it really has changed
who can have access and really improve things for patients,
but also for the entire
lung cancer community and future patients.
Yes. The other thing that in terms of that, that our policy
team has been working on is that
during COVID, one of the great things about COVID was that we did
so many more virtual physician appointments.
We sort of got around those laws of
if you're licensed in Texas and you're talking to a patient in North
Carolina, that's okay.
And then once COVID kind of faded away, all of those
laws came back into effect. So that's one of the things that our policy team
has really been working on, is to try and get that changed
again so that patients can have virtual second opinions, and
that it will make it easier for patients to
participate in clinical trials that are not near home, so that they can
actually have a virtual appointment with their
clinical trial doc.
Thanks very much for your presentation. Dan Backwards from Ohio State University.
I was wondering if you've found there to be any sort of disconnects
between what patients want and where the research field is directed.
I was struck, for example, when I'm talking to patient advocates
about my enthusiasm for immunotherapy, how they were sort of
against the idea of immunotherapy, saying, "It's great, but
I would rather take a pill for ALK or for ROS or
whatever." They were much more enthusiastic about
particular types of treatments and then targeted therapies towards them.
I was just curious if you had any thoughts in that vein.
Well, as a nurse
and not an advocate, I can tell you that
patientsAnytime they don't have to go
to their physician's office frequently, they're going to choose that
option. And that's just
practicality, right?
I do think in the advocacy world, one of the things that we do try to
do, again, is to really educate and to
help patients understand why a pill may not be
the best option for everyone
and where all of these therapies and
opportunities come into play. We talk a lot about
the different phases of clinical trials and the fact that clinical
trials should not be discussed at end of
life, that they should be one of the very first discussions that you have
with your healthcare team, because there could be a clinical trial for you even in
first line. So,
to really answer your question directly, yes, I
do think that patients have a lot of different perceptions
about what's right for them, and
to me, and as a nurse of 40 years, it's really more
about just lack of education. And I've always told
my patients, and I still tell our lung cancer community
today, that we will support you in any decision you
make, even if it's to do nothing,
as long as you are making that decision educated.
So I really think that's the key there to your question, is
that they think they're more interested in
certain forms of therapy until they really understand it.
Thank you.
Okay. Lunchtime.
Well, thank you to all of you for
attending and participating in this session today.
Thank you very much for our speakers.
It's been a wonderful session, and it'll be exciting to see
what we have to talk about next year when we
get together again. So thank you.